[Music]
animal agriculture looks very different
from farm to farm but there are many
common threads farmers and ranchers
manage complex systems to be profitable
and productive while also protecting
natural resources this video focuses on
NRCS conservation practices commonly
used in animal agriculture
the Department of Agriculture's Natural
Resources Conservation Service or NRCS
and the Environmental Protection Agency
or EPA each have a role in encouraging
farmers to use conservation practices
NRCS is role is to provide technical and
financial assistance to farmers who
voluntarily implement conservation
practices EPA's primary role is to
ensure compliance with federal
regulations such as the clean water and
clean air acts EPA also provides grant
funds that are often used in concert
with USDA program funding to accelerate
voluntary conservation practice adoption
these funds can be used to demonstrate
innovative practices coordinate
implementation efforts or provide
technical assistance and landowner
outreach state governments do and local
governments may have additional
regulations or guidelines beyond the
clean water and clean air acts NRCS
conservation practices can provide
numerous environmental benefits and
often help farmers meet environmental
regulations at the same time a variety
of practices are available to farmers
and ranchers some practices may be
relatively easy to implement while
others may be more complex this is
because every farm is unique every
situation is distinct and every solution
is customized the conservation practices
selected need to reflect the values and
priorities of the producer and the local
resource concerns and landscape
characteristics while all producers do
not implement the same conservation
practices there is one very obvious
similarity among all animal operations
the need to carefully manage activities
and sources such as manure silage
leachate milk house wastes chemicals and
animal mortalities to prevent nutrients
and pathogens from negatively impacting
Natural Resources the main categories of
conservation practices used on animal
operations to protect natural resources
include
manure management land and pasture
management and mortality or dead animal
management
many conservation practices aim to
prevent manure from contacting clean
water for example diversions roofs and
gutters direct water around production
areas systems to collect and store
manure keep it contained until it is
applied to fields where nutrients can be
recycled by growing crops manure storage
allows farmers to avoid application at
times when there is a high risk for
nutrient losses such as when soils are
saturated frozen or snow-covered losses
by runoff leaching and/or volatilization
can result in adverse effects on soil
water and air quality manure treatment
often addresses both air and water
resources two of the most common
treatment processes are composting and
solid liquid separation treating manure
can reduce its volume and moisture
content this adds value because it's
more economical to transport to fields
where nutrients are needed or to other
uses off-site
for pastured animals common conservation
practices include prescribed grazing and
access control prescribed grazing is
managing the location of animals to
maintain healthy vegetation soils and
habitats farmers and ranchers can also
use fences stream crossings or livestock
watering systems to restrict livestock
access to surface water while providing
for their needs for crop fields nutrient
management is an important conservation
practice it seeks to optimize the
application of nutrients for crop
production including reducing excess
nutrients which are vulnerable to runoff
or leaching for animal feeding
operations that receive technical and
financial assistance from NRCS
nutrient management must be documented
in a comprehensive nutrient management
plan or CNM P a CNM P is an NRCS
document that considers the entire farm
system and includes collecting and
storing manure land application of
manure nutrients and using farm and
field mapping to ensure manure is not
over applied or applied too close to
wells streams or sinkholes a CMP aims to
reduce soil erosion and potential water
and air quality impacts of in
appropriately applied nutrients other
conservation practices implemented in
crop fields focus on slowing down or
trapping runoff at the edge of a field
using buffers or filter strips this way
soil or nutrients are captured before
they reach a body of water wind brakes
can be used around barns or Lots to
reduce odors
an inevitable reality for livestock and
poultry farms is animal mortality
farmers can use conservation practices
to plan for both a small number of
animal losses during normal production
and for a large number of animal losses
during a catastrophic event good
mortality management protects natural
resources by preventing the spread of
pathogens or disease-causing microbes
farms of all types and sizes can engage
in conservation efforts farmers can
protect natural resources while
maintaining or improving production
through a wide range of practices if a
farmer or rancher has a conservation
need there is probably a practice that
can help fulfill it and assistance to
help implement it
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]